[Musique]
niché au coeur du Vésinet se trouve une
bâtisse un peu spéciale la villaberte
autrement appelée la hublottière de par
ses petites fenêtres rondes sur sa
façade latérale elle a vu le jour à
l'automne 1896
[Musique]
classée monument historique depuis 1979
cette grande demeure et la première
Maison Art Nouveau du célèbre architecte
Hector Guimard c'est à lui que l'on doit
par exemple les édicules et entourage
des stations du métro parisien des
lagrides d'entrée la ferronnerie
témoigne du style Guimard avec ses
courbes fines et élancées en coup de
fouet
[Musique]
la maison s'élève sur trois niveaux et
chacune de ces façades est singulières
sur la façade principale quasi
parfaitement symétrique l'architecte
alterne pierre de taille brique rouge et
meulière on retrouve partout sur la
pierre et la ferronnerie la ligne courbe
élément propres au mouvement Art Nouveau
de nombreux arabesques ornent la
Baptiste notamment au-dessus des
fenêtres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur la façade arrière complètement
asymétrique une double arche souligne le
perron de l'entrée quelques mètres plus
loin trois fenêtres obliques véritable
puis de lumière révèle la cage
d'escalier intérieur
[Musique]
autre trésor les plafonds décorés en
vague de stuc et poutres de bois
la villa est un lieu privé mais ses
propriétaires ouvrent exceptionnellement
ses portes au public cet été elle est en
accès libre jusqu'au 21 juillet et du 6
au 30 septembre de 9h à 15h au prix
symbolique d'un euro
[Musique]